the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 video as you all
know we are only days away from finally
getting to see the great battle between
the living and the dead the White
Walkers and the army of the Dead are
within sight of the Starks castle this
will be one of the most intense episodes
in the show's history this is a day I
have been waiting for ever since I saw
the opening scene from the first episode
as of right now the army of the dead
outnumber everyone at Winterfell in
order for them to win this battle they
may have to try to kill the night king
before his entire army kills all of them
first obviously this will not be very
easy according to Bryan Stark
he says the night king is coming for him
so he wants to wait for him in the
godswood
they hope the night king will separate
from his army in order to kill bran they
don't know if the dragons will work or
not but as of right now that's their
best weapon now before we get into all
that let's look at some of the other
images from the trailer here we could
see Sansa Stark and Arya Stark
overlooking the battlements Sean's is
finally getting her first glimpse of the
army of the Dead you can tell by the
look on her face she can't even believe
what she's looking at if you remember
Ned Stark used to say the White Walkers
haven't been around for thousands of
years
White Walkers have been gone for
thousands of years so he was like
and my mind sees what he sees songs a
most likely thought they were just a
story old nan will tell them when they
were kids now she realizes everything
John said was true then they show Varys
and Gilly down in the crypts of
Winterfell again this is the same scene
from the first official trailer we also
see Tyrion Lannister's down here as well
Daenerys made sure he went down there
because she said she's gonna need him
later she doesn't want to lose him
during the battle he wasn't very happy
about that but it does look like he
listened maybe this will lead to some
interesting conversations between Tyrion
and Varys
I'm already wondering what they will say
here we can see beric Dondarrion and
Sandor Clegane it looks like they're
about to go back outside
berrak sword is on fire so I'm guessing
they have already been fighting Sandor
Clegane is looking right over his
shoulder maybe that's when the army of
the Dead have made it inside of the
castle he might be making sure they
aren't coming up behind him as they go
back outside here we can see Brienne and
Jaime Lannister getting ready to fight
the dead this is most likely right
before they make first contact Jaime
Lannister looks goofy as hell in that
stance I'm guessing this is right as the
army the dead are about to slam right
into them now what's interesting is we
did not see any sign of the night king
when his army did arrive at the end of
the last episode we were able to see a
lot of White Walkers but there was no
night king now as I've said before we
may not have seen the night king but I
do believe he is very close by I think
there is some evidence of this in the
trailer for the episode let's look at
some of the images I think there are
some small details that do suggest the
night king shows up at Winterfell for
the battle there is also something else
that you should consider this will be
the biggest battle in Game of Thrones
history do you really think they would
leave the night king out of that battle
I don't think so
no I do still think the night King could
have a strategy of his own but I don't
think he heads south without his army
actually I want to start the video by
looking at the ending of the second
episode let's go to the very end when we
can see the White Walkers and the army
of the Dead when John and Danny go
outside to see where the army of the
Dead are at it is not snowing in that
scene it's obviously very cold outside
but I don't see any snow falling from
the sky the same thing can be said when
they show the White Walkers I do not see
any snow falling so it does seem like
the night king
not there as of right now we will know
when the night King is about to arrive
because he always brings the storm we
did see this happen at hardhome when
John tried to get all the wildlings to
Castle black
then we saw this happen again when John
and company went out beyond the wall to
capture a white
then we saw it again at the end of
season seven when the night king
attacked the eastwatch-by-the-sea the
night king does this every single time
he's about to attack when HBO released
their trailer for the third episode
there is a scene where we can hear
Johnson oh say the night king is coming
john knows because he has seen the night
king do this several times already so
when the White Walkers show up at the
end of the second episode the night King
is not there yet
but he does show up later in the battle
like I said in another one of my videos
the night king will most likely make a
very dramatic entrance into the battle
he will show up the shift the momentum
back into his favor now let's look at
some of the other images near the end of
the trailer this has to be much later
into the battle now we can see there is
some heavy snow falling onto the
battlefield and we can even see Daenerys
Targaryen flying her dragon into the
storm this is when the night King shows
up the fight now right before the battle
begins we can see all of their soldiers
and formation if you look to the top
left of the image you can see Danny's
dragons in the sky Jonathan Aerys went
up to the hill to get them ready their
strategy is to keep the Dragons back
until the night King shows up to come
after a brand you can already see theon
greyjoy us out in the godswood trying to
keep brain safe he doesn't have very
many Ironborn men so I'm not sure how
long they will last we will most likely
see Theon Greyjoy died trying to save
bran
if they can get the night King into the
godswood that's when they will unleash
the Dragons now I'm not entirely sure if
we will see Jon ride the dragon during
the attack on the night king I'm
assuming that he will because you can
see just how far away Jon and Danny are
from the battle the dragons will be the
only way they can get there fast enough
we already know Danny rides dragon into
battle because we can see her flying
into the storm however somehow Jon Snow
does end up on foot he also loses his
big heavy fur coat we can see him
standing here on the battlefield and
he's no longer wearing that fur coat
this has to be much later into the
battle you can see that there is snow
falling all around him and he does have
a terrified look on his face I'm
wondering if something might have
happened to one of the Dragons maybe
even the dragon that Jon was riding the
dragon might have been killed even as
jon was riding it maybe that's how he
loses his
fur coat and ends up on foot I really
don't know now John does eventually make
it into the gods what during the battle
you can see the trees are right behind
him in the photo and you can also see
the snow is coming down in the photo as
well I'm guessing this is right when the
night king comes into the gods what
after bran
you can clearly see that John has
already been fighting for quite some
time he does not look so fresh and so
clean like he did when him and Danny
were overlooking all the soldiers this
will be near the end of the episode
I even think this is when John will
challenge the night king they had to
have included this in the trailer for
good reason the camera focuses on John
snow as he grabs Longclaw I think it's a
very dramatic moment in the episode
since we can see John is in the godswood
now I'm thinking this is gonna be the
showdown against the night king this
means John and the night king are no
longer on their dragons so there is a
very good chance that both of them could
be dead now you may be wondering what
happens to John and Danny during the
battle do either one of them die no
matter how the battle ends I do think we
will see John and Danny make it out of
there they will go on to live another
day I know they make it out of
Winterfell because there is still one
scene from the trailer that we have yet
to see John and Daenerys do eventually
make it down to Dragonstone so I know
they will not die at this Winterfell
battle we still have to see that scene
when John and Danny are together at
Dragonstone if you look at the photos
very carefully you can confirm the
location of the scene first let's look
at one of the images we know his own
Dragonstone here we can see Tyrion
Lannister this is from season 7 episode
6 when Tyrion and Danny are talking
about Jon Snow now try to focus on the
decorations right in front of the
fireplace now if you look at the scene
of John and Danny you will see that both
of those decorations are there as well
you can see the very tops of them on
both sides of Danny let me show you
those again so you can get a good look
now focus on the shadows that are on the
wall at the fireplace you can see those
exact same shadows in the scene where
Tyrion is sitting in front of the
fireplace in my opinion that is
definitely dragon stone so we know John
and Danny do make it down here
eventually that obviously means John and
Danny do not die during the battle for
Winterfell now whether the night King is
still alive or not is anyone's guess I
cannot confirm what happens to the night
king at the Battle for Winterfell all I
know is John and Danny do make it down a
Dragonstone even if they defeat the
entire army of the Dead they will most
likely not be able to live at Winterfell
until some heavy renovations are done
the Starks castle will suffer some
significant damage not only will there
be a hundred thousand dead bodies lying
all over the front yard but there will
also be several fires all around the
entire castle we also know the army of
the Dead make it inside of the castle
because we have seen them running after
Arya Stark now it's hard to say if they
will have to abandon Winterfell during
the battle or not they might not have to
run if that is John challenging the
night king in the godswood
if John is able to kill him in that
scene then we should see the rest of the
night king's army die almost
simultaneously also don't forget every
time they kill a white Walker it will
also kill all the whites that white
Walker reanimated we won't see someone
fight the night king until the very end
of the episode but if they're able to
kill most of the White Walkers then we
could see the night king lose thousands
and thousands of whites just by killing
them that's who all the main characters
should aim for first go for the White
Walkers until the night King gets there
now I know that's easier said than done
I know I know I am very excited for the
upcoming battle this Sunday I hope they
are able to kill the night king in this
episode but if they aren't at least we
know John and Danny do make it out of
there to fight another day now we just
have to hope Danny's dragons don't get
killed in the battle either let me know
what you think about the images from the
trailer do you think that I king shows
up for the biggest battle in Game of
Thrones history I think you will now he
may not fall into their trap like they
want them to but I do think he shows up
and fights John in the godswood
we are only days away from finding out
so I guess we won't know very soon
anyways I want to thank you all for
watching another video and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]